hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast achieving higher
throughput with multiplexed phage
display presented by dr. Thomas Hank
stone software product manager molecular
devices
I am Alexis Krause of lab routes and I
will be our moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to by lappers and sponsored by
forte bio for more information on our
sponsor please visit for Tobiah comm now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. Thomas Kingston dr. Thomas
Hanksville is currently a product
manager for software compliance with
molecular devices prior to joining the
company he received his PhD in
biophysics and biochemistry through a
joint international industrial program
between the University of Natural
Sciences Salzburg and Genentech
incorporated the development of the
multiplex phage display workflow
described in the webinar was a product
of his PhD program dr. Hank so you may
now begin your presentation okay well
thank you Alexis for this nice
introduction and welcome today to
today's webinar about multiplex page
display which is a rapid peptide
discovery and screening platform
so a little bit about myself in addition
to what Alexis told you I did my
bachelor thesis in cremes which is in
the lower Austrian part as well as with
the cooperation at Genentech where did
the actual research lab and the bachelor
thesis was about developing peptide
binders against Donna catshark this is
where I really started to get excited
about Sage display in my master thesis
our validated and Alternatives antibody
scaffold for the use on stage which was
on a different University but again that
Genentech and for my PhD thesis I
actually put together my own project
which was multiplex page display which
really optimized every aspect of phage
display and used the latest and greatest
technology to improve throughput but
also the amount and the detail of the
data that was generated since 2016 after
I finished my PhD I'm now product
manager for thought mix Pro which is a
compliant software provided by molecular
devices and the connection between me
and for the bio which I have to point
out here is that fortifier actually
moved into the molecular devices
conglomerate as a business unit but but
my PhD work itself did not have to do
anything with molecular devices or for
Tobiah this was completely independent
and below you find my contact
information all right let's get started
so a little bit about myself you already
heard that as well as for the biomedical
devices now we'll give you an overview
about the technology so you know what
they expect from this webinar brief
introduction to phage display for those
who aren't that familiar with this topic
and then we're going to have two main
topics which is the introduction of the
technology itself by an example where I
develop peptide binding to LR 86 this
work has already been done I have
deliberately chosen this topic or this
person
because it has already been done and we
knew at least partly what to expect as
well as the second topic which focuses
on the throughput since we are stating
here to have a high throughput stage
display technology I will also show you
an example where we have taken advantage
of this technology to its full extent
and at the very beginning we have
obviously the Q&A session all right
before we get started with the actual
topic we're
pushing out a polling question to you
and what I would like to know from you
is what you see is the biggest
bottleneck and stage discipler workflow
as you do it we have four options either
library generation page appending lead
candidate characterization or data
analysis all right so technology
overview what we're going to do is in
multiplex page display so first you
start off with a regular facial display
process but instead of doing page
decoration essays to basically evaluate
the page concentration we're gonna come
in with the qPCR this is nothing new to
suspend report in the literature but
what we are doing is actually so we are
using bar coded primers as well as we've
optimized the qPCR so you can use the
product from the qpcr straight for
next-gen sequencing since we use barcode
of primers everything from one plate can
now be pulled into one cube can be
sequenced and after the sequencing you
get the peptide count how many times one
peptide was in the library so don't
worry if you don't understand everything
at this point here and hopefully you
don't but this is what we're gonna
through gonna go through in the webinar
in a very close detail and what we have
found and this is new at least I haven't
found it in literature at the point that
was doing my PhD is to actually
calculate signal-to-noise ratio which is
usually done by Sparta lies us from also
sequencing the background in this well
now we have the next-gen sequencing
results and typically what we see from
there is a bunch of lead candidate but
we all know that the abundance of a
phage clone in a certain library doesn't
necessarily tell you about the binding
affinity so what we gonna do isn't this
is also another technology I've
developed during my PhD is the stripped
of it infusion technology and within a
single day and by ordering one single
DNA primer you can actually
biophysically test your lead peptides
on the architect system and this is also
extremely high throughput compatible so
ideally by the end you have next-gen
sequencing results as well as
biophysical data which gives you a very
clear idea of what's going on in your
library and what your lead candidates
are alright so let's get started for
those who haven't really worked with
page display and couldn't didn't have a
clue what was going on in the previous
slide so phage display is as the name
session of phage is a bacterial virus
and we use it as a display system so we
would like to display something on the
surface of the page so as every virus it
basically you have a capsid as well as a
DNA that is enclosed if it caps it and
encodes everything that requires
required to assemble the virus so what
people found is you can basically clone
this the gene that's responsible for the
capsid and edit on top of the original
copy in there so what's happening is
you're getting a mosaic so this means
you can theoretically use the additional
copy to to get something into this agent
to have it displayed on the surface so
these are the two different systems this
is the the 100 penetrant 100 percent
penetrant system and this is called a
patriot system and we will be working
with a phage hood system here so what do
I mean you could take advantage of that
so what you can do is you can purify the
statement out of the page and by having
DNA library where every primer and here
we talk about a lot of different primers
like 7 to the power of 11 and higher so
these primers essentially encode
peptides
so what you can do is you can basically
align those primers to the stage met by
a technology that's called Hong Kong
mutagenesis which is what you see here
so you have a single-stranded template
you anneal the primer then you transform
everything into bacteria get the second
strand which has not been modified
adjusted and you end up with with the
segment where the new DNA have to change
DNA is incorporated if you transform all
of that into the coli Ecola will produce
the bacterial virus where now the
surface of the virus basically displays
your peptide and what's shown here in
five copies is typically a library of 10
to the power of 10 modified sage so you
have quite quite a diversity in there
and ideally depending on the length of
the peptide you encode the full amino
acid spectrum there our target protein
as I said before is lr p6 this is just
randomly chosen I wanted to use
something that has been saged before in
order to show the compare comparability
between multiply page display and
standard page display and 2lr p6 itself
so our p6 is a cell surface co-receptor
of the beta-catenin pathway and has been
shown to interact with dk k1 but we are
not focused on the biology we were more
interested in the technology here all
right so let's go through the technology
in detail and see how we actually detect
peptides and develop peptides here so
our target protein gets coated onto the
well there are typically three different
options how you can immobilize a protein
for phage display so either you directly
code it on the wall or you add the
biotin code streptavidin and use it this
is a linker to kind of prevent in
duration which is happening in the well
or you featured in solution and pull it
pull down the page complex and the the
protein complex together down here you
will see an illustration of the plate
what has been used for for the phage
display and as you see we only use one
well at this point and the green ones
always the target reaction containing
the target protein and the orange one is
the control reaction which in our case
is just it blocked a well that has been
blocked with BSA alright so look let's
look at the the molecular what's
happening on the molecular level here so
we have the protein coded on the well
and we have a control well that's coated
with BSA sort of individual is a
molecule furniture now you add your page
library
and the idea is after an incubation
period so every phage that displays a
preferable mode it's actually bind to
your bite your target president but
there is also nonspecific sage that
hangs around under well so after you
wash it away what you would like to see
is in the control well nonspecific sage
that is bound through well and B is a
and pretty much anything that's all in
the target well with the exception of
the the violet sage here that is target
specific so theoretically if you
subtract those two from each other you
should only end up with with the violet
page so how do I know when I can stop
this aging process
well what you can do is a qpcr so you
take the illusions from the phage
display and you conduct the qPCR we're
going to have a look at the results in
the interviews that get here but if you
don't see enrichment in the qPCR what
you would do is you would reinfect
bacteria you would amplify it amplify
the phage and now you get an enriched
library so everything that's not found
got washed away and you only have the
page that got enriched and they
obviously multiply by the thousands all
right but now here how do we determine
if actually there is more phage in our
target reaction than in our control
reaction we do qpcr and the qpcr is done
is followed so you have a reverse primer
the finds down stream of your region of
interest which in our case is the
peptide but can be up to four hundred
base pairs and you have a barcode root
forward primer the points upstream and
the loop barcode that's really just some
DNA sequence that's unique and we have
96 primers so for each well we have for
each library we have a separate primer
this helps us at the end to basically be
multiplex the whole reaction again so we
have sequencing adapters we have the
phage refining sequence
and we have the same thing on the
reverse primer so at the end of the day
what we would like to end up after the
the read the sequencing reaction is the
sequencing adapter a barcode that is
specific for the well so for the library
the five front binding the target region
the 3-prime binding as well as the
sequencing adapter
so in the qPCR itself multiple things
happen so first of all once we amplify
them but we would like to see that Delta
cities are different in where the
binding curves are coming up because
this actually means so if the target
reaction is coming up sooner this means
there must have been more phage in our
target reaction than in the control
reaction and the only way this is going
to happen if if there was target
specific page and another important
thing up here is the plateau phase so
what we have done is we have tested out
how low we can go with the primer
concentration and we keep the primer
concentration the same for all wells so
this means although the target reaction
is coming up sooner it hits the same
plateau so at the end of the day all
reactions in here have the same DNA
concentration which makes it really easy
for us to pull them because if there
would have been a concentration
difference even at the end we would need
to adjust the libraries in order to get
the same numbers of sequences from the
next gen sequencing so this is the data
what we saw and we've done that for
every round and although we already saw
in Richmond in the first round so we
probably could have theoretically start
stopped here we continued and we reduce
the amount of bait of target protein and
at some point which has reduced it too
much and we didn't see that much
enrichment anymore however so we took
the round 4 but for this case you could
have already stopped for round 3 and we
also analyzed these reactions
so the control definitely came up later
than the target which means there was
enrichment and we're good to go with
sequencing so as I said since we have
this barcode this unique barcode in here
we can actually pull the library from a1
together with the control library and
any other library we have so this means
you really can fill up fill up the full
plate and that it really works we will
see in the second application and
presenting to you so you take
eliquids of essentially all of your
libraries and you pull it into tube then
you mix it and
then we are already good to go with
sequencing just a little overview what's
happening so one piece of DNA get
encapsulated with with the D cleansing
bead and this is the ion torrent
technology Illumina works exactly the
same you just have to use different
adapters so then you do an emulsion PCR
the whole bit gets covered and then you
flush it over the chip surface and in
one ph-sensitive bucket one beat covered
with DNA ends up and it's
single-stranded next you flush the the
nucleotide triphosphates over the
sequencing chip and obviously primer is
attached here as well and whenever there
is a binding event from a biochemical
perspective the binding event of trying
to clear tight results in the release of
the pH and this can be detected by the
pH sensitive layer since it's happening
everywhere what we get from the next gen
sequencing is a vast amount of sequences
the vast amount of sequences so
typically we we have somewhere between 5
and 50 million sequences depending on
the technology you need but it usually
need for your library is somewhere
between 10 and 50 thousand sequences per
library and that x on how many libraries
you're sequencing so the bioinformatics
are fairly simple we use the bio Python
script for that which I wrote myself so
you take the fast queue file which now
contains all the sequences from your
plate and you take and since we know the
sequence of the barcode we can now
demultiplex the individual sequences
into the files then we trim off the
5-prime and 3-prime region so we end up
with the inserts which are the peptides
then we translate it and then we take
each peptide sequence and we count how
many times we find it in the target
library and how many times we find it in
the control library and from that we can
calculate a signal-to-noise ratio so
this means we don't have to do any
facial eyes anymore but this is already
our signal-to-noise ratio and this works
really nice
so you end up with a list of lead
candidates of total abundance as well as
the signal-to-noise ratio and since we
know that the abundance isn't enough we
have to physically characterize them but
here we don't have any DNA so we need to
synthesize our DNA these were the
results from the next-gen sequencing we
used 50,000 we analyzed 50,000 sequences
per library what you see is this peptide
here has the highest as far as the
highest abundance this peptide here
shows a high signal-to-noise ratio
suggesting that this is not a
nonspecific binder and the same for this
peptide the 14 highest ranked binders we
used in characterized KT value
so how do we now get actually a peptide
how we produce a peptide cheap and fast
so what you do if you can you create
another primer but in this case we set
it up for in vitro translation rather
than next-gen sequencing so we add the
five prime untranslated region a start
codon the peptide which in our case are
now the 14 highest rank binders so we
look for the peptide sequence in order
this primer as well as the script Ovid
and binding sequence and the same for
the universe the reverse primer but this
one is universal so you only need to
order a forward primer for each peptide
you would like to test then you do
another PCR reaction so and you use the
regular 457 for instance with the
streptavidin insert I would recommend
reducing the GC content because even the
GC content of streptavidin is extremely
high and you can get problems in the PCR
so you need to order a GC content
reduced version so now you do the PCR so
you end up with the double-stranded DNA
product of the five prime untranslated
region a start codon the peptide of your
interest and remember this is DNA the
streptavidin stop as well as the in
three prime untranslated region and
piece of DNA we are now going to use an
in vitro translation reaction so once
again this whole process is still
96-well compatible so it's very easy to
test 96 peptides at a time for a very
cheap price and extremely fast because
all you need is to order it is primary
here so for one peptide you need to
order one primer in the in vitro
translation reaction the double-stranded
DNA template and you can use straight
PCR template that of course you need to
purify it but you don't need to do
anything else
so you add it to a 5 micro liter in
vitro translation reaction and this
reagent can be ordered through any be
and after one hour the DNA has been
transcribed into mRNA as well as already
translated into protein and with an
attached peptide so you now have have a
tetramer of streptavidin as it naturally
is at a premiere attached to your
peptides of interest and you have that
for 14 different peptides and also this
is fully high-throughput compatible here
all you need is a multi-channel pipette
and in the next step we can use before
to biotech system to characterize all of
this peptides in just two hours so full
96 well plate can be run through in 2
hours so you get biophysical data of 96
peptides in only 2 hours and for the bio
offers different versions depending on
the on your throughput starting off with
a single
biosensor measurement devices all the
way to high-throughput 384 the
technology how it is going to work is
you have an optical layer and you have
immobilized molecules which in our case
will are the streptavidin the peptides
fused to streptavidin you have light
coming in and it's reflected and it's in
phase here but if you increase the
thickness of the layer meaning a binding
event is happening there is a phase
shift and you can calculate the KD from
that so what's happening now is with the
bio sensor which is ventilated you only
need to dip into the in vitro
translation reaction for one second and
in one second this extremely high
affinity of streptavidin for biotin
pixels picks up enough material for you
to go into the next well and measure
binding to your target protein and then
you go into the dissociation well and
you can measure dissociation rates and
this is once again fully high-throughput
compatible so it's no problem to do that
with 96 peptide at the time the peptides
at a time and after this experiment you
get your KD value
these are a takeda values for the 14
peptides we measured the blank tip and
only streptavidin
as a control which are down here
if we now look at the summary we can
actually find some really interested
findings which have been in general have
been reported in literature as well so
for PNA KGC this was the and top one
peptide in the NGS and it still shows up
as the top one peptide after the
biophysical measurement also number two
was extremely was a very good binder in
the micro molar range
whereas number three is quite a surprise
although a drunk ranked number 17 it
showed up as the third tightest binder
and what's also very interesting is that
this peptide down here as well as this
one which showed a very high
signal-to-noise ratio didn't show
binding to LRT 6 at all so this kind of
confirms what we see from the
signal-to-noise ratio as well as this
peptide which was the third most
abundant NGS peptide in NGS this one
didn't show binding either
and in order to confirm the biophysical
data we got from the accept system we
also measured synthetic peptides
although you see some difference this is
perfectly fine because we use the system
to confirm the binding
so in order to summarize the findings
for lrp 6 here is the highest ranked
binder contained n aik which is a motive
found in amiran DKK 1 which interacts
with a 1 unit of lr p 6 so this makes
sense that two systems may be stabilized
the peptide and lock it down in a
certain configuration and the glycine
prior was the one residue that didn't
disturb the the motive the least because
we used the sera more peptides library
so the conclusions for MPD here more is
better
70 out of the 100 most enriched peptides
were not detected by picking 96 clones
which we did side by side
the second most abundant peptide in NGS
wasn't even found by picking clones so
you would expect to find at least second
most abundant finding the picking 100
clones but we just didn't so this is
what you would miss if you only pick
clones
counting sequence abundance is also not
enough
so from our experiment the binder that
ranked third in the NGS did not even
show binding whereas number 17 did show
quite nice binding so how much time did
it take in total
for MPD we usually calculate nine days
for a full a full 96 well plate
after the enrichment process which might
worried between one and four rounds you
do the qpcr and NGS which is done in a
single day as well as the primer
synthesis and in vitro translation which
is calculated with three days we left
two days for ordering primers and one
more day for the biophysical
characterization so the advantage of
standard phage display versus multiple
XH display yes first of all throughput I
was able to handle the six library
reactions at a time with multiple page
display I was able to handle a full
plate and the proof of throughput you
will see in the second part of this
presentation monitoring of enrichment is
done and plating out titers whereas here
it's qPCR and you also already end up
with your sequencing reactions
sequencing done Sanger sequencing and
here NGS to rather than receiving a
hundred sequences per library we ended
up with 50,000 sequences per library
the city city here it is determined by
spotty lysis here you can already use
the NGS data and don't need to do any
additional experiment the binding
affinity is sometimes done using five
stage separation the list
eliza's here we can measure absolute
affinities using the streptavidin fusion
technology alright so how about
throughput and this project or this
experiment really demonstrates the
throughput of this technology so here we
show you a technology to in and also map
the linear epitopes of 96 antibodies we
have 41 individual clones antibody
clones 7 controls and everything was
done in duplicate and this little
experiment took only 2 days and we used
two complementary technologies for that
the script Ovid infusion technology as
well as multiplications plan as an
example protein we signal peptidase baby
which has been determined identified as
a target to treat Staphylococcus aureus
infections
and its purpose is to cleave signal
sequences
so SPSP in short has been ejected into a
mouse and using standard hybridoma
technology 41 individual clones have
been harvested from the mouse what we
now need to know is where do those
antibodies bind on the on the protein
and this technology is really only for
linear peptides not for 4 so for
continuous peptides not for
discontinuous with no structural
epitopes and everything was done in to
placate
so the big question really is like where
do my antibodies bind to because this is
extremely important for any further
characterization so what you do is you
start off with the streptavidin fusion
technology so this was the sequence of
the protests and what you do now is you
take twenty or minor acids and you
synthesize another primer and you take
the next twenty another primer and so on
and so forth and in this way you're
covering the complete protein so you
have primers for every region of the
pregnant
then you do again descriptive it
infusion technology and you end up with
double strand DNA pieces peptides few
streptavidin
having all the in vitro translation
features
again you do in vitro translation and
you produce peptides and now you've
basically your complete protein in
peptides
what you do now is you take eight octet
tips and you cover and you load or load
your epitope specific peptide
and you basically do that for every
peptide for every epitope peptide and in
one run you're going through the
complete plate so this means every
antibody actually sees every epitope of
your protein
so you don't even need a target protein
all you need is the sequence and you
sent and you basically produce peptides
to what you then see is as you go
through the plate
if
with hope basically matches the antibody
or let me put it the other way around if
the antibody recognizes the epitope you
will see a binding event and what you
see here is the analysis so this was we
basically now been the antibodies in two
different epitopes
sometimes you see two binding events
because we designed two layers in order
to also cover the regions where one
habit of peptide basically touches the
other one so we just did two layers of
peptides this is why you can see two
binding events so what we would now like
to see in the phage display experiment
is an epitope that basically is right
where it - peptide so what you do now is
you in order to confirm the results we
have seen from the streptavidin
technology you now coat the antibody
onto the well so now you have a 96-well
plate and decode an antibody in each
well
now since the antibody is immobilized on
the well you actually add a phage
display library a random phage display
library and what you what we think that
would happen is that the antibody will
pull down phage that this place epitope
like motive on its surface so every
antibody essentially grabs the phage
that this place and motive that
resembled the antibody and this was
actually confirmed so if we look at the
antibody clone for each seven where this
is the epitope where it binds the
buy-ins
biomechanical analysis for this was done
in tripeptides so we chopped off the
protein SP SP into tripeptides
and we're matching the sequence to two
peptides where we see a good signal to
noise ratio
if we now combine the two analysis
methods in order to confirm the phage
display results with before the buyer of
pet we found from 41 antibodies 12 have
unique epitope and this was extremely
helpful for the subsequent
high-throughput screening campaign
because rather than testing 41
antibodies we're down to 12 and remember
this experiment was done in two days
because we didn't have to amplify the
phage but we just put it on top washed
it eluded it and used it straight for
qpcr next-gen sequencing
so this is the end of the second topic
and we would have another polling
question for you so having seen this
presentation would you be interested in
being contacted for additional
information on the architect system here
general acknowledgements are to Bob
Lazarus at Genentech who was my mentor
and gave me the opportunity to compare
this project in his lab the SBAC team at
Genentech helping me out with the
antibodies which I obviously didn't
raise myself the oligo team at Genentech
I needed over $1,000 for this project as
well as the Life Technologies team which
provided me with a sequencer and a lot
of support in the beginning to get
started from the next gen sequencing
these are the references which where I
took information from in this
presentation and now available for
questions thank you
thank you doctor hang stuff for your
informative
patience we will now start the live Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started doctor hang saw a
first question is does this technology
also work for larger frameworks
hi Alexis can you hear me I can yes
excellent thank you
so this technology also works for larger
frameworks the only thing that has to be
validated is the qPCR so we tested the
technology with six different frameworks
and for instance for one of the
frameworks it didn't work at all there
was something with the structure the DNA
structure of the framework that wouldn't
let it to be like properly amplified in
the qPCR I guess we could have optimized
the DNA sequence but bottom line is it
does work but it's the different work
itself needs validated
now our next question is did you use any
automation
we did not use any automation
besides the devices we have basically
shown in the presentation so we didn't
really use any liquid handler all we
used with a multi-channel pipetting and
we
I was really focusing so that this
technology can be conducted by a single
person I mean you don't even need a
next-gen sequencer you can really send
that out to two other companies what you
need to do is you need to prepare the
library but no automation is needed
besides the octet which was shown and
the next-gen secrets
now dr. Hank sell do you include only
randomized peptide sequences or do you
find flanking linker sequence can affect
by bait
so we read so for the library design we
actually did include the glycine and
serine linker to make sure that the
pepper is properly spaced to the code of
the page and we did the same for in the
octet system so when we basically fuse
our peptide to streptavidin we also
include liquid air
next question is how do you amplify
libraries from multiple targets that's
that's a that's a good question yeah
first we we were thinking of actually
amplifying them separately but that
would essentially destroy the whole
point of some of the technology and when
you think about it you start off with a
completely random phage display library
and so what you can really do is you can
pull the libraries from your complete
plate and amplify them together because
there is nothing going to be in there
that wasn't in there in the beginning so
when you then continue your aging
process you just take this one master
library and put it on top of all your
targets because if there's any
nonspecific peptide in there you will
see it in the Chrome
so you can really amplify it all
together just pull your page library
amplified overnight maybe a little bit
longer because you need more phage you
need to cover the full plate but no need
to keep them separated just pull them
all together
now is there a limit to the size of the
library because you have you had only
50,000 peptides in your library so
terms of dicta could be some I'm not
really sure with the size here means the
first of all the insert we were limited
so I was basically provided a sequencer
by thermo I only had to buy the chips
but they provided with the sequencer and
I'm not sure what their size limit is
right now back then it was around 400
base pairs but I know Illumina can do
like double-sided sequencing so this
really was the limitation to the
technology if you can insert longer
insert then there is no size limitation
the other thing the cookie meant by this
question is the number of sequences you
need for per library so what we found
this depending on the enrichment it is
helpful to have either between 10 and 50
thousandths and that's you know that's
just that's just a rule of thumb with
today's technologies you can easily have
like a hundred thousand verb per library
and this is really just a math thing so
if you have for instance if you can
sequence 5 million sequences and you
have 5 different libraries you would get
a million if you have 50 libraries you
only get a hundred thousand but in
general as a rule of thumb somewhere
between 10 and 50 thousand is if you see
enrichment should be enough
so now our next question is could you
use this technology using other NSG
modalities not NGS chip-sequencing
yes absolutely the only thing you need
to adapt this the primer sequence
so if there are no I'm going to give it
just a couple more minutes for any other
questions that might pop in looks like
we have another one right here yeah I
think we can also answer the other
questions
so let's go with number 10 did you
analyze if some of the peptides have an
advantage during amplification
um very good question so there's
actually literature out that and people
have also developed technologies to
basically so we know that there are
peptide sequences which are preferred in
the amplification process and there is
um so there is for instance droplet
amplification and there is a really cool
technologies out there but what we found
this we we can completely ignore that
because if
if it only amplified due to a preferred
peptide sequence that would essentially
drop out in the analysis with your pet
and this is why it's extremely important
to have a large pool of lead candidates
because you really can't tell if this is
a preferred peptide sequence so you just
take a bunch of lead candidates and you
test them on the octet and your pet will
give you a clear answer if this is
really a good binder or this was only
due to a preferred peptide motif
now dr. Ansell can you comment on the
sensitivity of the different Forte bio
instruments and the size of the peptide
associated on a biosensor
all right let's think about the question
for a sec
so in terms of in terms of sensitivity
there are different accept instruments
up there which obviously do offer
different sensitivities we have used the
octet red system which was sufficient
because we had we had the octave we had
the peptide on the tip associated with
streptavidin so we always had the target
in solution but if i'm more than happy
to basically forward this question to my
colleagues and i know that there have
been peptide experiments conducted with
your pathetic where you could turn it
around but for our technology it was
more beneficial to have the peptide on
the tip and in this case you usually
have a larger target molecule or for the
dissociation and association measurement
i hope that answered the question but i
will in any case forward that to my
colleagues so they can give you a more
detailed explanation for that
and there's one last question left here
can you get the ji pzr results on the
same day and the answer is yes you can
get that just a little ad here which I
didn't join the presentation you might
want to do a quick buffer exchange cause
typically depending on what you use for
or illusion this might inhibit the PCR
reaction
so either you do a quick dialysis or a
couple of hours or or a different method
to basically exchange the buffer
all right so if we have no more
questions we'd like to thank you again
dr. Hank Silla and do you have any final
comments for our audience
no but if anyone's interested in the
technology so the technology specific
question about page display feel free to
forward them to my to my email address
and yeah that's it before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today or those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank
laborat and our sponsor for teh bio for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through March of 2019 laboratory via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share the email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
I